nous sommes vendredi et ses jours de
cinéma pour judiciaire 22 ans qui se
prépare pour les séances de 13h30
aujourd'hui je vais sortir au cinéma
pour voir le prix de france grâce au
pass loisirs le pass loisirs dispositif
mis en place par le conseil
départemental permet aux personnes en
situation de handicap d'accéder à des
activités sportives culturelles ou de
loisirs et le pass loisirs a permis à
judiciaire de découvrir de nouvelles
activités
j'ai fait elle est là dans hélicoptère
et gravelines depuis qu'elle reçoit ces
pass loisirs judiciaire sort plus
souvent et c'est le cinéma qui remporte
tous les suffrages
la semaine dernière ce sont les mignons
et cette semaine elle part à la
découverte de l'histoire du petit prince
c'est une bonne chose pour le pot les
gens qui handicape et aussi ils peuvent
faire des trucs avec leurs parents et
tous là et c'est bien pour eux aussi dit
qu'elle pourrait venir
elle voudrait bien regarder le petit
prince donc du coup on a regardé quand
est-ce qu'on a une le temps parce
qu'elle a des trucs à faire aussi les
mardis et jeudis donc aujourd'hui et là
ya pas de fric à faire d'un côté on peut
voir des petits passent et des coups
après on a téléphoné les taxis donc les
taxis va venir en mesure et demi pour
vous emmener jusqu'à cinépalmes de
sainte-marie l epal vie elle est
contente elle se sentait bien qu'ils
volent et jean normal c'est pas comme
elle qui est tout le monde est là c'est
pas que les enfants qui a les qualités
ou les gens quelles difficultés mais il
ya aussi d anormal donc ce mélange est
donc tout le monde est pareil quoi il
est 11h30 judiciaire et sa mère
s'apprête à prendre le taxi en plus
contente juste là les uns
autre dispositif du conseil
départemental le pass transport permet
de payer les déplacements en taxi ou aux
cars jaunes qui est handicapée est par
exemple un médicament n'a pas bégayé
avec ça et c'est grâce aux baisses
transports que la course sera réglée ont
fait 25 euros les loyers des tickets qui
tolèrent s'associer la voyez là il faut
toutefois il faut que les personnes
quand je gagne ce message nous c'est que
la facturation sur vous direction le
guichet pour cette fois-ci reggae la
place de cinéma
la carte d'identité de judicial est
essentiel pour vérifier qu'elle est bien
la détentrice des pass loisirs et pas de
films sont des bombes - grignoter après
ce passage obligé judicial sa mère se
dirige vers la salle de cinéma les
dispositifs passera par transport sont
deux dispositifs individuels des signes
aux personnes porteuses d'un handicap
donc le dispositif se présente sous
forme de chéquier de chéquier de passes
choisir d'une valeur de 270 euros et
deux chéquiers par transport d'une
valeur de 300 euros
les critères d'éligibilité déjà pour les
passes ou loisirs c'est percevoir
l'allocation adulte handicapé pour les
personnes adultes et l'allocation
d'éducation enfants handicapés pour les
enfants mineurs et pour les personnes
aussi qui perçoit une pension
d'invalidité catégories 2 3 de la cgss
et peuvent prétendre ne pas choisir au
sérieux ces dispositifs donc faudra vous
appelez au niveau du conseil
départemental à la cellule pas choisir
par transport aux numéros suivants au 02
62 90 37 90 ou sinon vous avez le numéro
vert qui le 0 800 00 8 952 vous réussi
nous joindre par mail à l'adresse
suivante passe et abs
@ 6 g 9 7
point fr